Yeah
[inaudible]
Like a boss.
I saw a couple, I actually saw a couple
of them went out and I saw, I go,
I saw that. And um, I liked it,
but it was funny when Ben Affleck, they
say, what's your name? And he goes,
my name is Tony Mendez.
Okay.
My name is Tony Mendez. I'm from New
York. My father worked construction.
My mother teaches elementary
school. I have one.
I remember thinking in my head going
Mendez, I think that's a Latino name.
I know it's not a white name.
I know. I've never met anybody.
I never met a white guy. Hey, what's
your name? I Larry. Larry. What?
Rodriguez. Larry Mendez.
It's not, you know,
it's not like one of those crossover
names. So in the end of the movie,
spoiler alert, they had, this
is just shit in the credits.
They just have a, you know, they
have a picture of everybody,
you know, each cast. Cause it was
a true story. So each cast member
is, um, you know, I should talk to
this, I should talk to Nia about this,
you know, this is, this is it.
We're going to do a fucking, uh,
another Neil log this week, and I'm going
to talk about this because they had,
you know, the six actors who are
fucking unreal, who played the, uh,
the people trying to get out of Iran.
They showed a closeup picture of the
actor right next to a closeup picture of
like the photo id of the person that
they were playing and it was fucking dead
on. They looked exactly like the person
[inaudible]
and then there's like another minute or
so credits and then they finally show
the real Tony Mendez.
And the picture is like a full body shot
of the guy from like halfway across the
room shaking hands with Jimmy Carter.
And you're looking at the guy and he
looks like Bartolo Cologne's dad and me.
And Nia just started laughing our
asses off and you know, it was,
it was one of those moments,
one of those Hollywood moments.
And then I looked on the internet
and it was people complaining going,
what the fuck? You know, how come you
couldn't get a Latin actor to do it?
But Bob [inaudible] done
all that shit. You know,
now you play a character in this film
by the name of Tony Mendez and a lot of
your fans don't realize that
you speak Spanish very well.
So I have to ask you and Espanyol to own
the upper in these Dale Espanol. Econdo
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, you
know [inaudible] [inaudible]
this is what I got to say about that.
I definitely think it's fucked up.
Why don't I just say what I had to set
about say about that? Like, like what?
I was just going to present all this
shit and then move on. All right.
I don't know how to say my points
without having some sort of intro.
And now here is what I think about that.
I think it's fucked up cause it
was a real dude and he's a hero.
He did some unreal shit.
So because it's a real dude
who did some real heroic shit,
you should have a Latin dude play the guy.
So everybody knows that that win
is in their column. You know,
that's one full Latinos, you know,
so the next time you get into
a barroom argument, you know,
well doe way Fed on the airplane and
then the Latin guy could be like,
yeah,
well we're the ones who got those six
motherfuckers on the plate and got him
into Canada. Right. And all of your shit,
both sides. You're in a bar, so none of
your read. It's all based on the movies,
but now it's going to cause a fight
in a bar because some of them,
yet it was a white guy. The guy's good.
No, it was fucking Tony Mendez
Essay his way. Fuck you.
The why was it played by Ben Affleck?
And then there's going to be a big fight.
But on the other side
is if you got a fucking million
dollars and you need the movie to sell,
what do you do? I still think they
should've. They should've gone.
Really should've got Luis Guzman.
Where the hell is he coming from this?
Why is he saying this?
Luis Guzman is Tony Mendez. I
know. Fucking know. You know what?
That's one of the ones that I got
to talk to the about that shit.
But it's a good movie. You
should definitely go see
it. But I got to tell you,
that was inadvertently
fucking hilarious. I'm like,
me and Nia walked out and
started joking about it,
and by the time we got
out of the movie theater,
we were crying and laughing and everybody
was looking at us like we were out of
our minds.
And the fake movie crew Mendez
was the production manager.
And for the cover to work,
he had to become a real one.
He opened a production company in Los
Angeles. He had business cards made.
Mendez played his part so well
that you could say at the time,
he might've been the best actor
in the world. And in a way,
you should've won an academy award for
the, for the role you played in it. Yeah,
that'd be a good idea.
We could have an academy
awards were spies for Mendez.
That's what passes it. Sarcasm.